[SPEAKER_00]: Fourth of Wealth, son, Jude, in battle.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, you're right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: You cast shield on this thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can't do it to someone else, by the way.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he's on the ground, isn't he?
[SPEAKER_01]: It doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_00]: If they threw it through a door slit...
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a feat to be able to do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can't do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fuck.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, let me see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just real quick.
[SPEAKER_01]: Give me...
[SPEAKER_01]: The bolt misses him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyway.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, let me mark down, though, that I did cast Fireball.
[SPEAKER_01]: You did cast Fireball.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty!
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus five.
[SPEAKER_00]: You get to do what you want.
[SPEAKER_01]: Motherfucker, I'm gonna cast Fireball again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Boom!
[SPEAKER_01]: Right through it, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I assume that they are at least...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're here, he's here, they're outside here.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I'm wondering is how big is the cone of Fireball?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because...
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a thing, it's 20 feet, so it's gonna be one, two, three, four...
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_00]: How deep?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then I cast Fireball again.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do I need to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to move?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or do you want to stay there and do your thing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I cast Fireball, grab him, and drag him back?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, the grabbing action is grab action.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you can grab him and pull him back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Firing and moving is me alone.
[SPEAKER_00]: But if I want to grab him and drag him out of the way.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a whole turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, let me, give me just 30 seconds.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think I have anything that's a heal.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I know I'm not a healer, but I was just trying to think if I have anything that's a heal at all.
[SPEAKER_01]: How fucked up does he look?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's bleeding from an eye thrust, like a dagger thrust to the eye.
[SPEAKER_01]: But obviously he lost his eye.
[SPEAKER_00]: I actually know.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that really- Oh, maybe it just hit him in the face.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: The bleeding's too much.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, then that's okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I cast.
[SPEAKER_01]: I gotta clear them there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even if they're flanking the building, I gotta clear.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I cast Fireball.
[SPEAKER_01]: You throw a gap.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm all about fast kills.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten, fourteen, fifteen, nineteen, twenty, three, twenty-four, twenty-five, twenty-five.
[SPEAKER_01]: Still take half damage, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: You have no idea what's going on.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hear more screams.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, well, you hear chatter, is all I can say.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's chatter?
[SPEAKER_00]: People go, ah!
[SPEAKER_00]: Diving bullshit.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know you're doing what Jude does, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Fucking killing shit, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: No firing inside...
[SPEAKER_00]: This round?
[SPEAKER_00]: The round.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, then I want to grab him and I want to drive him back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next round, roll an ish.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have to roll an ish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jam 2 plus 4, so 6.
[SPEAKER_01]: You go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I'm going to take them around the corner.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you grab them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so I grab them and drag them.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's an action.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then 1, 2, 3 to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And him and I are on the same square?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the door had not been broken down?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: The door was open.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, does this represent his shop?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, can I assume that, do I know from his shop, is this a back door?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a door.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know this.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a stairwell going down.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a door.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, door, door, door, door right there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like I'm backing up towards the door?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, door, but whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: Going down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, is it my turn or do I just do more or do they act?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you can actually have a very short conversation right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: How do we get the fuck out of here?
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're being targeted.
[SPEAKER_01]: You.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or both.
[SPEAKER_01]: The sewer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Should we go down?
[SPEAKER_01]: Down.
[SPEAKER_01]: The sewer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so then I'll move that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hang on.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's enough time.
[SPEAKER_01]: What?
[SPEAKER_00]: The door breaks down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, fuck.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which one?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, that one?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, some powerful... Oh, like other, like not a human being.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, well, Karmur, the level is correct.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: A powerful something smacks that door down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Also, I cast another fireball.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, I had already invised myself, so I've actually used my rings in disability, correct?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I hear this.
[SPEAKER_01]: How far is this?
[SPEAKER_01]: Five feet?
[SPEAKER_01]: You can move 15 feet dragging him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, so is he up on his feet?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, can we move?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can we gash?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cause I want to get him up on his feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's gotta move.
[SPEAKER_01]: I gotta get him to move.
[SPEAKER_01]: Four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Five.
[SPEAKER_01]: Four plus... Plus four is eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_01]: A guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: A guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: A creature.
[SPEAKER_00]: With the head of a snake.
[SPEAKER_01]: And a fucking ripped body.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it one of the fucking Naga?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or like one of their fucking Yon T-shirt?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, because I've been with the Brotherhood.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll a wisdom check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fifteen, plus...
[SPEAKER_00]: It is jaunty.
[SPEAKER_00]: Motherfucker.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you see this.
[SPEAKER_00]: And actually, you have kind of a flashback.
[SPEAKER_00]: It does not fuck you up.
[SPEAKER_01]: The flashback doesn't fuck me up.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you're like, holy shit, they're here.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is straight up fucking Scarlet Brotherhood, Jaunty shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is Scarlet Brotherhood, totally.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to do right there?
[SPEAKER_01]: There he goes.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I do a wall of fire...
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I barrier off this whole section right here and make it to where like they go?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, like they haven't broken through that and that's the Yon-T guy, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I totally do a fucking wall of fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude conjures wall of fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna put that, that's my fourth level, and get one of those.
[SPEAKER_00]: Up across the Alchemist lab.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, the wall of fire exists.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then I take him, if I can still move, or drag him.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, one, two, three, you pull him to here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your wall of fire comes up.
[SPEAKER_00]: This burning inferno of craziness.
[SPEAKER_00]: And roll, because I believe, let me look at wall of fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I think when it comes up, it's like a lot of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, especially, I want to make sure it's in front of him though, so if he does suffer damage, like I'm trying to prevent him from going into the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't take a Yanti solo and drag this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it does have like a sort of a, I think it's like a 10 foot or a 15 foot.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, uh, it's a 60 foot long wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, yeah, so that's easy.
[SPEAKER_00]: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I just... Do you want to do it like... Yeah, I'll do some of it that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like this?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: The corner of those guys, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, so you basically make that wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: It does five day damage to the guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five day?
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: These things.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so let me see.
[SPEAKER_01]: So eight-sided, eight-sided, one, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll those in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll one.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got one more.
I got it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got five.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight, twelve, seventeen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Holy shit, that's a lot.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's seventeen, twenty-three, thirty-one.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then, um, 31 set.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, the guy is like, ah!
[SPEAKER_00]: Motherfuckin' Naga.
[SPEAKER_00]: Burning back on T. And he is looking out.
[SPEAKER_00]: His head is like a snake.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like I said, I made my role.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a yawn-tee motherfucker.
[SPEAKER_00]: You actually recognize this guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Silent Brotherhood.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, Scarlet Brotherhood bullshit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And you drive the Alchemist back to there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wall of Fire, we gotta get out and we gotta get to the base.
[SPEAKER_01]: The guy said on the ground he better not be delusional.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you said that he doesn't look that bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: He doesn't look like he lost an eye, but he's gotten gouged by a dagger in the face.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he's still bleeding profusely.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think that I need to stop and try to save him.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can drag his bleeding ass down there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I get it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I get it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you're gonna have to be tough.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're gonna have to be tough enough like you were young.
[SPEAKER_01]: Rollin-ish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twelve plus my intelligence is four, so that's sixteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your dexterity is actually what's important.
[SPEAKER_01]: You saying I won?
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your dexterity?
[SPEAKER_01]: My dexterity, yeah, it's plus four.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's eighteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's true.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's why Jude is Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I was gonna say.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the only thing that's kept me alive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hanging is the fact that I'm fast as fuck and I'm smart as shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I wanna dash.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I can dash.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if I can.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, what you do is pick the guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: And even though he's kind of blinded,
[SPEAKER_00]: You run towards the stairwell.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because it's the only thing that I know that goes down.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you begin running down the stairs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, bring him with me if I can.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the two of you descend into the darkness.